nous pourrions nous rencontrer quelque part
mon conseil
je vous exhorte à voir la vérité de la
situation dans laquelle vous vous trouvez
ce n'est pas à moi de vous dire ce que vous
auriez dû faire ou ne pas faire chaque
action produit des conséquences qui
créent de nouveaux mondes
ils sont tous différents
le conseiller, c'est une sorte de gars ordinaire,
il travaille de la frontière au mexique,
il est tenté d'entrer dans une sorte de
monde plus trouble où il pense qu'il peut
gagner un peu d'argent rapidement, il y a des
conséquences à cela
la faiblesse du conseiller est qu'il pense
qu'il est plus intelligent que  il est qui est un cul intelligent
oui, en
gros, il sort de sa
caméra de mort
le monde dans lequel il investit est le
monde le plus sombre
c'est juste la pire idée de
ce que carmack est si bon pour révéler
les côtés les plus sombres de ce que les humains sont
vraiment vraiment capables de faire pour  les uns les
autres et ce que fait Ridley, c'est de le
rendre vivant,
vous pouvez penser qu'il y a des choses dont
ces gens sont tout simplement incapables,
ils ne le sont pas,
allez-vous m'aider, continuez-vous à nier
la réalité de t  le monde dans lequel vous êtes il
n'y a pas de choix il n'y a qu'à accepter que
le choix a été fait il y a longtemps
je dirais que le conseiller est une
figure classique de la tragédie un type bien qui se
lève un matin et décide de faire
quelque chose de mal et c'est tout  prend
que c'était un crime grave
si vous n'êtes pas dedans, vous devez me dire que je
vais bien,
vous savez que c'est de la cupidité, n'est-ce pas,
c'est l'occasion de
saluer dans tous les sens,
de la manière dont nous voulons
saisir et tenir et posséder des choses et  aussi
posséder des gens
et se posséder pour ne pas
abandonner à l'autre
tout le monde en veut son petit morceau
parce qu'ils pensent que c'est cool et ils
pensent qu'il y a plus ils veulent quelque chose
pour rien c'est ce que le conseiller
vient après la
vie ne va pas vous prendre  de retour mais
pour ceux
qui comprennent qu'ils
vivent les derniers jours du monde, la
mort acquiert
un sens différent,
vous avez besoin d'un peu de courage en vous pour
vraiment sauter dans le monde de macarthur et
creuser
parce que vous pouvez voir mince  gs ou entendre des
choses que vous ne voulez pas entendre ou
affronter c'est un avertissement c'est chaque
scène vous dit
que vous subirez les conséquences de
vos actions alors considérez vos actions
vous réalisez à quel point tout est entrelacé
et lié c'est la condition humaine
alors quoi  arrive ensuite
vous êtes le monde que vous avez créé et
quand vous cesserez d'exister ce monde que
vous avez créé cessera également d'
exister
nous en avons tous fini ici
c'est hors de votre contrôle
il est trop tard
avez vous été mauvais